欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一个关于市场参谋, 如何去选品, 选推广国家, 选词, 去打造爆品
那么我们这个板块所讲的内容就是比较单一, 它只针对这个板块去选品, 去打造爆品
这里面我们首先第一个维度就是打开市场参谋, 找到查行业
查行业的之后这里会有很多个行业
那么这么多个行业里面会有一些具体的数据维度给我们去判断参考去选择对应的类目
先选择类目然后再确定类目的前提下去选择类
那么品类确定了之后我们就可以去选择对应的一个产品
以及推广的国家, 以及我们要用什么样的关键词去组合形成这个产品的标题, 然后再去推广
那么我们选择判断的指标, 第一个有供需比, 第二个是转化率, 第三个是产品的款式, 第四个就是偏好时, 第五个就是偏好国家, 以及其他的属性
那么在这里我就不将这些展开详细讲解了
因为到后面我们会有一节专门的市场分析的一些课程
在里面会具体的分析这些各个指标
那么接下来我们就按照具体的操作来实操演示一遍
让大家能够更加快速的去掌握这个方法
第一个选择的判断指标就是选择款式偏好指其他属性
我们直接到后台去看一下
首先我们打开的这个板块是市场参谋
市场参谋之后我们选择查行业
查行业之后这里会有很多的品类
这里会有很多的二级类目
这些人看到了
那么我们是根据刚才所讲的一个是
供需比转化率以及市场的一个增速
来判断我们店铺里面优先选择哪个品类
作为重点的主供品类
主要是推广或者是加资源的服务池的品类为主
比如说我们选择一个蓝装
我们就点蓝装点击之后进来之后我们就会看到这里有产品嘛
这些蓝装的产品有人气榜还有飙升榜还有蓝海榜效果榜
这里面去选择应的产品款式
有些公司是不选品的
但是你可以参考这些类型去选一些什么风格属性材质等等功能
这些产品都行
关键词榜单也可以去选一些关键词
当然有些行业是没有关键词的
这里没有的话我们就不用参考这里的嘛
我们接着就去看一下这个行业
它的主要的一个成交的国家是哪些
比如说这些国家
我们之前也有讲过怎么去看
你看这里有的一个选择交易买家, 询盘买家
选择不同的维度
那么这里的国家是不一样的
从这里选国家
这里选择国家之后
我们是不是就知道我们这个类产品
要推广到哪些国家已经明确了
那刚刚我们是看不到关键词的
我们刚才已经确定了这些国家
我们把我们要的国家筛选出来
针对每一个国家
你看这里查国家
比如说我针对美国
我就去看美国
它的一个偏好的这些关键词
看到没有
这里有词了吧
你就来这里看这些词
顺便看一下它美国所喜欢的款式
那么你词跟款式搭配在一起
也就是你选了好的款
再用这些词主标, 那么你整体上的就可以组到一个比较连向这个国家偏好的产品链接了
比如说你要选第二个就是英国, 那么你按照这个思路, 点击一下英国, 进入之后也是按照这个逻辑
或者是说你有更加精细的内幕的话, 你直接比如说我就做这个内幕了, 那么你也可以选择更细分的维度
那么下面的数据就会更加的准确
如果你觉得这里的关键词, 比如说这里的关键词太少, 找不到, 不够组合标题, 那么我们可以来买家参谋这里看
一定要选择更细分的维度去看, 订单买家, 选盘买家, 还有TM买家, 看时间维度长一点点, 往下拉, 你看这里不是有词吗
有行业买家偏好词, 还有买家全站的偏好词, 这些词, 你都可以把它整理出来, 然后去组合标题, 再去推广
其实这个思路还是比较简单的, 主要一个就去选品, 第二个就是你确定了推广国家, 然后再去选这些国家偏好的关键词, 再反过来去组合标题, 再去推广, 推广的时候你又把这些国家锁定词, 也锁定所有的资源都集中在比较精准的一个范围内去做一个推广, 成功概率会相对来说比较大, 当然有可能就是你组标题的时候做的不好, 或者是说你选款的时候选的不好,
也会导致你这个计划可能没有测试得出有潜力的链接
所以我们要结合我们之前学习过的主标题的方法
加上之前我们选品的一些方法, 选国家的一方法
你可以按照这个思路去征合的应用
也就是你不要局限在只在这个市场参谋里面去选择
我们还有其他的维度,比如说行业的榜单, 买家参谋, 流量参谋等等
这些维度去综合的去选择, 最后进行对比之后, 再确定我们要选哪些品类, 哪些词, 哪些国家, 再去做推广, 就可以了, 推广的过程中, 如果有数据了, 比如说有寻盘TM了, 你一定要记得去补充一些订单, 因为没有订单, 它就不能形成一个有效的流量闭环, 因为流量闭环是流量到寻盘到TM, 再到订单, 订单再反过来就会给这个产品,
增加一个权重, 来提升你这个产品的排名
产品排名提升了是不是它的流量就会更多
流量多了是不是它的寻盘会更多, 寻盘多了是不是可能订单就会更多
这就是完整的一个闭环
所以很多时候我们推广到一定的程度都是有寻盘跟贴母
我们如果本身线下有比较多的订单
或者是我们也有一些老客户
我们看看能不能把一些线下的订单来绑定一下
我们现在正在推广的这些产品让它形成一个有效的数据闭环
这样对我们店铺的整体的一个爆款打造是非常非常重要的
这个环节被很多人忽视
所以你在打造爆款的时候一定要注重寻盘到订单转化的这个环节
因为缺少了这个环节很多产品都是有很多寻盘变成了寻盘量很少
最后面就这个产品流量也少了
最终就导致这个产品变成了一个普通的产品
所以这个一定要重视起来
我相信这个能够帮你更快的去打造爆品
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见